another compound which she discovered
which
um wasn't around in your great great
great great great grandfather's time
is something called oxybenzone
let me just read that there because
these damn things are so oxybenzone
um which is used in sunscreen
so when you're going out buying your spf
whatever thinking that you're protecting
yourself from the sun you probably are
but the thing that makes it see because
they always call it uh
you know 24-hour hydration and 80-minute
water resistance you can
swim for miles and you know the stuff
never comes off it's very effective at
blocking out the sun but the problem
with oxybenzone is
it's estrogenic so in the male body it's
estrogenic
it basically mimics estrogen and your
body receives it as estrogen
which is why you see so many guys today
walking around
you know with female breast tissue and
very very large midsections like there's
there's an epidemic of obesity
in north america and again that's why
the subtitle the book is this is why
you know we are fat sick and infertile
today
so we've got atrazine which uh is
a um which is used in agriculture
sorry uh we've got oxybenzone i'm using
words that i don't normally use in my
normal
vocabulary i'm just trying to recall
what it was that anthony j used in the
book so we've got
oxybenzone which is used in sunscreens
all sunscreens in fact unless it's zinc
based
so if you're going to use sunscreens use
zinc based
sunscreens i i titled this one uh
tongue-in-cheek don't be soy for a
reason so you guys can learn something
um
but you know there's some truth to it
because soy is also a problem he's he
spends a lot of time in the book
uh on soy and how that's estrogenic in
the male body and they use soy in a lot
of
um foods as fillers
i picked up a bag that
was supposed to be natural organic
healthy uh homemade potato chips
basically at this grocery store the
other day
you know the equivalent of like a whole
foods and i flip it over and look at the
back of it
and it's got so soy protein in it um
as part of the dusting you know for the
flavoring
they put it in everything and you
literally have to look at the packaging
of everything that you pick up to see if
they've thrown soy in it as a filler
because that shit's not bad like it's
not good for you um
it's it's fine if you're a chick it's
fine if you want high estrogen levels in
your body
uh soy sauce is fine because it's
fermented according to dr anthony j
so that's totally fine if you're into
sushi which is a good thing because i do
like sushi
um but you got to watch the labels of
foods that you're eating
atrazine as a as a herbicide again stuff
you put on your body compounds
toiletries so a lot of toiletries have
um
i can't remember the name of it in his
book but um trust me when i
when i say this actually i'll grab the
link because i got it over here i'll get
to the super chats in a sec guys
i got the link here from the interview
so i want you guys to just open this up
in another
uh window if you're watching this on
your desktop if you're watching this
later just search on my channel
playing the win number 21 how
estrogenics make you fat sick
and infertile with dr anthony j and i
can't remember for the life of me what
the uh
toiletry compound was i'll put that
there in the chat but
um soaps shampoos
anything you put on your skin has this
compound
and you'll start to notice it because
when you start to look at the
ingredients less it's got [ __ ] on it
that you can't pronounce
and it's not one thing it's going to be
dozens of them
these are the ones that you want to keep
off your body and i laugh when
you know guys are like oh rich is a soap
salesman well there's a reason why i
like this product
because i can actually pronounce the
ingredients and there's only
one two three four five
six seven eight on this one that's it
it's you know it's a handmade pheromone
if you soap
that won't disrupt your endocrine system
i guarantee your cheap ass
shampoo that you've picked up in the
giant bulk container
at uh costco or your you know 37 000
pack of soap of irish spring it's got
all of that nonsense in it you want to
avoid that as much as possible you put
that crap
on your body it gets through you on your
skin you eat foods that contain soy it's
going to get into your system
and all of these things are going to
make you estrogen dominant which is
going to destroy your testosterone
levels
you